welcome to this video against town Tevin
um tell Kevin nope yeah I was also my
memory there is no name attached to the
account okay it's going for the semis
love playing a somewhat slow line
against that with Quincy to be three
this is some solid yeah they keep
playing that and I'm I'm I'm kind of
miss playing it I think yeah how do you
play that actually should be two is
probably not right somehow i feel i'm
having done something wrong here Knight
takes Knight be five i recently lost
badly in this in this line cannot and
let's let me figure that out night be
far that's Bishop f5 this is what I
recently overlooked not be five Bishop
f5 which was a super bad position then
but it's probably it's difficult here to
avoid default right if I go Bishop e2 I
mean hmm yeah I'm kind of inventing this
year over the board not really knowing
the details now okay so okay now if I do
not be five now he has rook c8 okay so i
could go Quint III now getting out of
out of the pin
yeah like black is quite active so he
should never be in trouble I know that
the doorbell ring and I cannot answer
that now
let's play this game it's probably an
important
okay it was uninformed let's see let's
see what happens here is going 94 yeah
that pin that pin is a bit problematic
hmm night your form should be too I go
night a4 to trade stuff I'm candidates
kind of its not very harmonious and I
still wonder I don't be too looks very
awkward if I go nighty for but if I
don't do that i might play Queen a5 even
increasing the pressure down now now
that looks bad yeah I miss played that
this whole opening is something that I
need to really have a look at i recently
saw some games with this be three line
quincy to be three but that's not enough
I'm kind of screwing the move orders up
the big issue here is that my dark
squares are very weak Roxy 393 Queen f6a
it's all about those weakened squares
and f2 is even under some pressure yeah
night a4 I guess it's not very beautiful
but what else I cannot really cover the
night well let's say covering it looks
also very awkward not good
you can take on f2 but i'm not sure if
it is so great i can play clets a queen
bee one and then it is a real pin 9f to
look after Queen a one would win the
exchange I actually did not see that
it's just lucky that I'm not immediately
losing me material him just lucky yeah I
guess that's also why he's taking a
valium because my position looks very
very suspicious yeah that's the that's
the normal let's say just intending to
go be five if possible
ok not that's not nice but maybe what I
need to do ok so maybe it's not that
terrible i have the c5 square knot c5 is
a possibility
this position might still be about okay
95
yeah tix here till then if for the
suppose my was my general idea but I
have no other way to defend III
still looking quite awkward but yeah
what can you do it's an uphill struggle
after this somewhat somewhat misplayed
opening maybe 95 was something that I
could have improved upon it's really
possible okay I cannot pick d5 now maybe
something like that trying to force the
trade can pre move that I guess you will
take i don't really know there's no big
trick and if he has to take almost if he
goes d4 i have 23 form for blockade the
queen is not the greatest blockade ever
okay so it's not doing that is playing
it in a simple fashion just Queen takes
should be okay for I think about
equality and I'm okay with being equally
of course and let's just bring the King
up okay so he's trying to go there maybe
I can put the rukon before
it is an equal ish time morning no g4
should have had a look at that move ok
can I go look before here one Roxy 3023
wow I almost have to play that check
that should be ok should be should be a
draw rly the group trade I mean and then
general probably as well ok it's trying
something like an attack be five or g5
ok take some things
check so this is hanging on g3 check
let's see you move this pawn up check
okay whenever you choose the Jeep horn
I'm check I'm here to tell you good
check check this is really a draw check
check unless he blunders hike with
capturing the pawn is this the leg last
little miniature trickier Gras our third
check black perfect I offered to draw
him it is really just a draw what can I
do I'm not resigning in a drawing
position with more time on the clock you
should just take the drawdown I offered
a bit late maybe but yeah he could have
offered before it's it's a draw for for
a while now yeah not the most satisfying
whenever I already miss play this
opening I keep doing that I should look
at up they they they often play five
here let's have a look them what is what
is going on here maybe I have to play
Knight be five in this moment at this
moment I don't know I think there is
some 95 business what it's not good it's
definitely to play i'm here i can tell
you this this and now night before this
is what I tried recently in abbenay game
and I got completely destroyed after
this move so that's not working the
problem is that i'm lacking in King site
development
and yeah Black is really in good shape
he can he can even go deform maybe if he
likes I worked he won this slightly
tricky maybe yeah he played it perfectly
okay i'm not trying to improve here a
lot it's just totally fine what he did i
went here which is awkward yeah but i
wanted to get rid of this pin the
deception awkward situation with the pin
plate a six i went here yeah i probably
have to do that and now he went back i'm
not sure maybe he should just play 93
this kind of position it's definitely
the okay FM maybe i'm looking for an
advantage for black and there is nothing
it's just equal maybe it looks it looks
kind of 0 with the e3 porn but maybe III
and d5 is kind of um canceling each
other out yeah here should be okay and
what's the computer giving equal yeah i
should be somehow okay but probably I
made a mistake here yeah this night f5
after that hmm maybe I should take b7 as
the comb suggests after that oops wait
oh now the computer is giving this and
since black is black is quite
substantially better why is that maybe
because of this check here right that's
possible if I hear he can give us a
check ah that's a very nice tactic okay
check check check that's very nice okay
so queen is six watch mark was much
stronger because I cannot really play
you for and if I cannot do that who
basically just was just losing the pawn
cool move a cool line okay here and
after that I'm kind of okay again okay
yeah he can try a default but i'm not
sure about this after queen d three
years has to go here
and well yeah they say the queen is not
the greatest blockade of it at least it
does locate the pond like here you can
try that yeah I think I'm okay here the
king is near the deep horn I'm worse but
probably not lost maybe you should do
that though I mean here it's just really
totally equal actually I doubt that my
route d4 before idea was that great I'm
kind of getting myself into some trouble
here nothing very substantial probably
but it's not really necessary yeah
chicks chicks check you and yeah I'm
like a slave black is better with the
active King I mean the drawing check
margin is so pretty substantial oh I
just blundered the rookie a rookie one
who oh wow oh and I really took some
time on that great yeah talk about a
lucky win check yeah I think it should
be a draw well very lucky win on time
okay I hope you are were entertained at
least it wasn't the greatest chess game
what time thanks for watching